foreign
within the vastness of the universe
humanity is not that big of a deal
we're not here because we're meant to be
here
we're just here
if mathematical predictions are correct
we might only have 760 years left
what would be the cause of our
Extinction
what would we do if we knew exactly when
our existence would come to an end
and could we delay the inevitable
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we knew the exact time when
Humanity goes extinct
1993.
in 1993 knowing that Humanity's time on
the planet is limited astrophysicist J
Richard Gott made a very daring
prediction using nothing but statistics
[Music]
basically he calculated that there's a
50 chance that the end of human life
will come sometime before the year 2779
that gives us 760 years to make our
final arrangements and possibly pass the
Earth on to a new life form or even
leave the planet to itself altogether
stick around and we'll take you on a
journey to the future of humanity
on April 13 2029 the near-earth asteroid
named epofus will pass within 31 000
kilometers of our planet
that's 10 times closer to Earth than the
moon is
and even closer than some satellites in
orbit
but this 370 meter wide asteroid won't
hit the Earth
instead it will sweep by safely and
continue its path around the Sun
reproductive technology would allow
parents to preview and pick the genetic
traits of their future babies
the global population would grow to
about eight and a half billion and reach
a crisis point
the world's ecosystems would change
faster than we've ever seen before due
to increased levels of CO2
up in the Earth's orbit everything from
spent rocket stages to debris from
accidental collisions would create a
wall of space junk
it would be problematic for any
spacecraft to leave the Earth
we'd have to find ways to clean up the
upper atmosphere if we didn't want to be
trapped on Earth forever
if Humanity managed to solve the space
junk problem we'd start establishing the
first lunar bases and that would Mark
the beginning of the permanent human
presence outside of Earth
20 45.
on Earth the global average temperature
would rise by one and a half degrees
surpassing the safe limit
even though Humanity completely switched
to clean energy sources
global warming would become catastrophic
and hard to control
due to warmer global temperatures the
Great Barrier Reef would lose up to 90
percent of its corals
the Amazon rainforest would largely be
destroyed by wildfires and deforestation
even after Decades of conservation
efforts at least one million species in
the wild would begin to go extinct
[Music]
this would be the beginning of the next
mass extinction event in the Earth's
history although this time it would be
caused by humans
the Earth's population would grow to 10
billion people
the Earth would become the hottest it's
been in the past three million years
extreme weather would Rampage around the
world
Africa the Middle East and Southeast
Asia would be most affected by floods
hurricanes and droughts
parts of the planet would become
uninhabitable leaving 140 million people
no other choice but to seek Refuge
someplace else
[Music]
biotechnology implants would become
available to the general public
resulting in humans merging with their
technology on a biological level
never failing artificial organs
synthetic blood and nanoscale brain
interfaces would become a new reality
sea levels would rise upwards of 6
meters forcing hundreds of millions of
people to leave their homes
large-scale evacuations and resettlement
programs would be needed along the
coastlines costing Humanity trillions of
dollars in the process
because of the declining fertility rate
and the significant number of casualties
from environmental conditions Earth's
population would stabilize at 11 billion
people
21.80
by the 2180s humanity would start
expanding into the solar system
mining asteroids and terraforming Mars
would be underway
more people would have access to space
technology and a new form of terrorism
would emerge
it would be possible to hijack a
spacecraft and use it to redirect
asteroids towards the Earth the moon and
Mars
the lack of space infrastructure would
leave space colonies particularly
vulnerable
[Music]
22 80.
spaceships powered by anti-matter
propulsion would take Humanity outside
the solar system
automated unmanned probes would be sent
to the far regions of the Galaxy
researching thousands of interstellar
worlds
by the end of the 23rd Century humans
would have confirmation of a microbial
alien life existing on a warm wet
exoplanet within a hundred light years
of our solar system
2300
Decades of nanotechnology research and
advancement would result in transforming
the general public into transhumans or
cyborgs
transhumans would have improved
intelligence and strength
among many superhero traits they would
be able to Sprint at very high speeds
become invisible or even transform their
appearances at will
2500
Humanity would level up from a type zero
to a type 1 civilization on the
kardashov scale
that means humans would be able to
harvest all of the Earth's energy and
use it to power up their entire
civilization
they would already be able to control
the weather and global climate
alter the course of earthquakes and
build cities at the bottom of the ocean
The Next Step would be developing ways
to fully manipulate the sun's energy
they might start building space
megastructures like a Dyson Sphere
or even attempt to feed some of the
Sun's mass into a black hole
27.79
the chain of the previous events could
lead to humanity completely disappearing
from the earth one way or another
we might end up moving to space colonies
we had established
or it may not even be us anymore but a
new biotechnologically engineered
species
of course this is a rough timeline
guesstimated by futurists based on
statistics and mathematical models
if you're upset about Humanity's coming
Extinction remember that it only has a
50 chance of coming true
scientists calculated our date of
Extinction using the same formula that
marketers use to predict what product
you might click on online or who you're
going to vote for
it's about probabilities not guarantees
[Music]
besides other predictions tell us that
we would face Extinction not 760 but 10
000 years from now
in that case we'd be around long enough
to see the Earth's poles reverse around
the year 3 500. and computers reaching
their ultimate potential sometime after
the year four thousand
but how would knowing all this in
advance change the way we live our lives
well if we knew the date of our
Extinction with 100 accuracy we could
stop caring about our environment and
our bodies
we might focus on all the bad habits
that only bring us short-term happiness
our society could become more violent
more self-harming more inclined to start
wars
or we could team up and try to get off
this rock
we could start looking for other places
to move to beyond what our own solar
system has to offer
we could establish colonies with stable
human populations
then even in the event of Earth getting
wiped out by some cosmic power humans
would continue to exist
they could carry on until the universe
itself collapsed and stopped existing
but that's a story for another what if
hey thanks for sticking around and
making it to the end of this video
you know you can help us to produce more
of these long episodes by visiting our
store and buying a shirt or a hat or a
hoodie
the leggings are cool and we sell this
pet with self-conscious AI
no just kidding
check out the products below the
description or click the link on this
screen
[Music]